hi there and welcome back to the future
of documents as always I'm Holt Skinner
previously we've looked at a lot of
different ways to process documents from
pre-trained Models to custom models and
everything in between but now what if we
need to store millions or even billions
of unstructured documents manage access
and compliance of those documents and
get insights out of them with a managed
service well document AI Warehouse has
the solution
it's a cloud-based fully managed system
to store search organize govern and
manage documents and their data in a
single platform it also acts as a
centralized Hub and storage repository
that can integrate with document
processing workflows
[Music]
when you're dealing with a large amount
of documents it's important that your
document management platform
incorporates four primary components
first the ability to automatically
extract and store detailed data from
your documents second search and
organize documents based on their
contents and metadata
third support for governance and
compliance layers to limit access
control and ensure auditability of your
documents
and last flexible Integrations to handle
workflows such as document approvals
reviews and Records management
let's look at how document AI Warehouse
incorporates each of these components to
handle document processing you can use
document AI to extract meaningful data
and key entities out of documents such
as contracts forms and invoices for
example Fields like contract number
invoice amount or employee ID can be
extracted and stored for searching and
filtering then you can search and
organize the rich content within a
repository of documents by performing
full text semantic searches on documents
and their metadata this means you don't
have to manually add keywords tags or
other sparse organization methods to
search through large amounts of
documents quickly for governance and
compliance capabilities you can select
from different Access Control modes to
choose the one that's right for you
document level Access Control lets you
specify which users and groups have
access to particular files using Google
Cloud Identity or a third-party identity
provider
finally you can build document workflows
with policies and actions that can be
used to enforce those policies you can
Define conditions based on document
types dates or values in specific Fields
like all invoices with an amount greater
than one thousand dollars
then you can Define actions that are
executed based on those conditions such
as changing the access control sorting
into folders updating fields or
triggering external workflows now that
you have a better understanding of the
core components of document AI Warehouse
let's look at a real world use case for
managing records and document approval
workflows
consider a set of contracts that we
might have to retain for a certain
amount of time based on legal document
retention periods
in this case you can first import the
documents from cloud storage and process
all the contracts using an OCR or
contract processor then group the files
into folders based on the vendor and
type of contract
finally you can define a rule and an
action that automatically updates the
access control list for the contracts
based on the amount of time that has
passed this orchestrated workflow
ensures that nobody can modify or delete
these documents until the document
retention period has been satisfied
today we've taken a look at document AI
warehouse and how it can be used as a
centralized platform for storing
searching and managing lots of documents
all with the scale of Google Cloud
now you have a chance to try it out and
see how it can handle your entire
collection of documents check out the
code lab link to the description for
step-by-step guides and be sure to go to
the cloud documentation for the latest
information thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
[Music]